Did we see the story this week?
This man in Texas was sentenced to 180 days,
about 100 days less than a full term pregnancy,
for drugging his wife seven different times,
attempting to induce an abortion without her knowing.
As a reminder,
Texas has one of the strictest
and most unethical abortion policies since 2021,
thanks to the Texas Heartbeat Act,
the law has essentially prohibited
any abortions after six weeks of gestation,
with no exception for rape and incest.
As a result of that law,
there can be very severe consequences for people
who attempt to help the woman who wants an abortion.
For example,
just attempting.
Medical professionals who attempt to perform,
induce or abort a pregnancy.
An unsuccessful
unsuccessfully
can face 20 years in prison
and a ten thousand dollar fine.
Medical professionals that successfully
abort a pregnancy can face life in prison
and no less than a hundred thousand dollars.
And family members,
friends, taxi drivers,
anybody who goes with them, helps,
pays for something,
can be helped,
criminally liable
as well as to find.
20 years in prison for a medical professional
who attempts an abortion.
But this guy who drugged his wife seven times
attempting an abortion
gets 180 days in jail.
This is just another example of how it has never been
about protecting the unborn
and it has always been about regulating women's bodies.